um my biggest take away from the game is
obviously we couldn't stop the run flat
out and simple um a lot of Cowboys fans
have questions about how we play home
and versus away and they're very valid
points and accusations because of our
track record so far versus us at home
and that's that way um I don't really
have an answer for you but I just know
that we need to play better we need to
get better there's no excuses obviously
after a loss like that we just couldn't
stop the run flat out and simple
um not getting into detail who's fault
who's blame it was a collective group
but what I'm seeing is like what I
understand is like everyone just waits
for the Cowboys to lose um I saw
multiple analysts people who are fake
analy who somehow got jobs on TV saying
there goes your boy like it's almost to
the point where it's like almost sick
that they're waiting for another a
former players are waiting for other
current players to fail so that way they
have something to talk about and I mean
it's not even to just get into names I
mean I feel like at this point you kind
of know who you are and it's like oh
there he is that's the person we've been
waiting for and it's like why do you
want a person to lose so bad as a former
player and as a current player I feel
like you like I'm a fan of the game
right whether I'm playing Josh Allen or
whoever at the end day I don't want to
see Josh Allen hurt I don't to see him
fail I wanted him to see how to continu
his career um at the end of the day
obviously when we're playing and we're
lining up I'm trying to beat him right
but it seems that a lot of people are
just waiting for uh people to fail and
then you get into the criticism and I
seen a lot of people saying well how do
we want to use Micah we shouldn't um you
we should use him more off the ball well
guess what there was times where they
move me off the ball and then y'all were
like well why isn't he rushing the
passer why isn't he doing this
it's almost like you can't like I said
teams will always play us differently
Josh all him averaging 30 to 40 passing
attempts so obviously we didn't think he
was going to come out and run it the
whole game and run consecutive plays
over and over again so I mean that's
obviously not part of the game plan but
it's almost like you can't always get
everything you want you you want someone
to rush and then you want someone to
stop the run be off the ball it's like
you can't you can't do everything and
obviously it's easy to point because
certain groupings is going to be in
certain Personnel it's a lot of
giveaways what coverages you can be in
is very predictable in NFL it's hard to
win an NFL at the end day it's hard to
play perfectly week in and weekend out
every day and that's just the reality we
seen it out of multiple great teams and
we never said the bills were a weak team
we always said they were a really good
team they just weren't producing to the
level they they should be and they
produced at that level back toback weeks
they arguably could have beat beat the
Eagles they arguably could have beat a
lot of teams they beat the Chiefs I mean
they're beating good teams the bills
have always been good it was just the
turnovers the beating themselves but
they never no one ever said the bills
were bad and that's just the reality of
it James Cook had a career night bought
out you know and that was the first time
we gave up over a 100 rushing yards to a
player before uh and that's just reality
I mean Josh even said I felt like a kid
that didn't do anything in the class and
in the in the class project and still
got a a Josh allenan beat the there was
a great team win you know he was seven
for 15 four seven passes might have been
drop back and other were play action and
things like that like they didn't want
to drop back the CR front they they they
made a goal and they got up in the lead
um we beat ourselves with three crucial
penalties that led to points that
continue drives and so forth but at the
end of the day we just got to play
better better we're going to have to get
better um we got opportunity next week
to go out and play the Dolphins and win
that game and that's all that matters to
me um it's just High Q bounce back after
you get smacked in the mouth you know
what I'm saying everything's all good
when you're on a high horse and you're
going up the mountain and everything's
good but it's time to get back to work
and get better cuz at the end of the day
we may have clenched a playoff spot but
it does not matter cuz we're going to
have to travel we're going to have to be
Road Warriors we will not be the number
one seed we're going to have to get
better at the end of
day